hello and welcome to our monday night
live show I hope I have a couple of
regulars in the chat looks like it and
I'm happy to start the games yeah let's
get a couple of five-minute games and I
really like to play some games having
done chess all day but haven't played a
single game myself so I'm happy to play
some some blitz games let's see I've got
a couple of there's a couple of them
starting oh I've got wide against whole
game that never happens how is that
possible even I've played 46 games
against them and I think it's probably
like 40 times with wide yeah okay and he
goes b6 which is not a big surprise he
always plays one be three I like it's a
good question here by a Sebastiao in the
in the check of a plan anything special
for my blitz video number four thousand
actually what I had planned was to
introduce the new layout with the webcam
but I felt it's no point in waiting with
that I have now this webcam layout
already am you're already going so
nothing in particular nothing in
particular planned okay so request for
the session is a Dutch Leningrad yeah
I'll try I mean if I get only one year
for it will be difficult but we'll see
um yeah what is my idea here I try to
put something on d 593 and so on okay he
is out for exchanges which is an
understandable strategy Black has less
space and trading is usually quite
helpful so we'll see him
it seems that he tries to cover yay
covers the d5 square I wonder what to do
a Halloween costume for number four
thousand um yeah maybe the hell
Halloween is just around the corner for
that huh hmm I'm not so much into that
so probably no costumes I'm just
stopping the immediate be 50 yeah
there's a message there by cheyenne
majumder that is playing mostly things
that John deform you and I have
published that that sounds sounds oh
yeah it sounds nice I hope you are
successful with our suggestions okay i
wonder if i should go 95 here or not hmm
it looks kind of illogical in a way but
it would prevent b5 at least for the
time being yeah let's do it I'm really
not quite sure
there's a question about the bank 0787
687 am not aware of the smooth I don't
think that this should be particularly
great to be honest ok let's look at this
game I play for h4 h5 which can be
irritating for black as we see he is
somewhat irritated him and goes age 5 ok
so here I'm not taking this this is
quite clear the question is can I do
something on the King sodium yeah maybe
this one f1 Queen h6 could be irritating
to him and I see it seems that he tries
to play be five year in this position
understandable queeny's free would still
prevent that maybe maybe do that it's
nothing special but oh interesting
interesting move
taking now is probably not a great idea
I mean ok I can do it but does it does
it really help is it something useful
for me I don't see a a good alternative
to be honest I don't see one yeah this
b5 i was thinking i can take and go 85 I
hope this is okay for me and I'm not
entirely sure actually I'm not entirely
sure Roxy to was a bit bit of an
annoyance yeah Brooksie to he might
double there I am he might double on the
second he has a temper only two and then
maybe we'll be true hmm ok so I'm
attacking the porn that was one idea
here
that's probably just equal anyway this
is just equal anyway yeah I will produce
content for the World Championships yes
i'm actually going i'm doing life i'm
doing some live commentary for the ICC
which is fantastic and I will do
something on my channel I guess as much
as I can yes I had a timberland
yesterday my german team won his match
in in but ghouls back which was nice
clap clap yeah he's getting AC six days
he's getting the his six porn this mech
part which was as dead soon there's no
need for content on the world
championship match because Carlton block
Russian anyway I don't think it will be
all that easy and it's still interesting
even if it is a even if even if cars is
actually winning the match clearly it
will still be interesting to see how is
going to do it so I probably wants to go
with these six tragic yeah it is just a
draw is the problem i would like to i
would like time wanted to do something
but I don't really have anything that I
can do this is just a draw
I think it probably has to take on b5
and this is very equal it's not much
that I can do the only thing of interest
would be f3 + g 4 so almost this
actually okay I'm glad this is almost a
maid idea then this is threatening made
you see aware of that I mean it probably
still doesn't really do that much but
maybe maybe I'm actually making mistake
here I don't know check
it's still draw a silly draw Chuck hmm
really and it's a good move
unfortunately our wait I can do this
threatening ruchi for mate and what are
you going to do now exactly I'm sorry
this is funny this is a funny funny
position
black forfeits on time yeah this is a
suit swung right really funny rook g4
mate yeah okay so that was a fun end but
it shouldn't should be a draw yeah
anyway so let's go for a new game at
least I'm happy with this is a funny
funny position yeah rook h2 I take its
let's not that's not a stalemate i think
is he could he could defend i think like
here here rook G fired home should
should be okay now that's a draw okay
I've got a new request out for game and
see what's happening game started front
o z there was a request for Dutch
Leningrad I can try a minute c4 but
still you can you can try can you give
us tips how to get such a young skin on
on our face like like mine that's funny
you really think I look that young well
I don't know so let's see this is an
interesting plan here with them with
them with e5 and c5 and recently that
was played against me in a blitz game
and I had huge problems that seem
this is why I'm adopting the same setup
here with black now
it's not not so easy for YTM to to play
this position my opponent in this game
just doubled on the F file and then at
some point I really didn't know what to
do so I am Kim yeah maybe let's put the
night in 2d for now a form yeah this is
a very principled move and move that in
in the mentioned game I never dared to
play because I felt that I'm getting
getting problems on the dark squares
with moves like this not sure yeah I try
to pressurize a form currently I'm
threatening a thing to take on d5 and
then take a couple of times on f4 with
Bishop b5 at the end almost almost oh my
god he definitely wants to kill me
hmm ok doesn't look good I probably have
some that looks very very dangerous for
me currently hmm I need to get rid of
this thing the bishop I mean
yeah he can drop back to g5 but I don't
think he will play for a draw here that
would be weird I probably would have
probably would need to accept this draw
it's very difficult to not do this and
it's not a good position really not haga
changes opening repertoire from b3 to be
fight resins white resins hmm sorry i
don't know why i don't know but maybe
yet to leave or something I don't know
is he logged on no disconnected hmm I
don't know that that's lucky I'm in my
position definitely is not all that
great ok game started new game against
your cheek let's go your shake c4 I've
got a minus five score against this guy
and I recently had a game against him
we're screwed up the opening quite badly
it's playing the same line again no I'm
playing it better this is something that
will be all released on my channel in
like next week or something I fail to go
into the slide I did something else
something bad b6 okay there was a
question what do I think of the latest
Nigel short controversy and I to be
honest and I don't know exactly what was
happening I only know that there was
something about the match that he played
against who you found it
I did not something with the last game
rate it or not rated or something I did
not follow it up in any any sort of
detail okay what to do what did you
probably look yeah f6 this is the kind
of move that I wonder about here I mean
I have nine txt five here i'm not sure
if he considered that probably not but
it still seems to maybe work i also have
night f 49 f 4 looks dangerous let's do
that
he wants the last game to be unrated
from I'm not aware of the world's I mean
the thing is with those rules um I mean
you can usually look them up and if he's
right he's right if not then this is a
weird thing to ask so I wonder huh I
have all kinds of things here 95 ft xe5
is the thing
Bishop h3 probably plays Knight f8 back
hmm all those tactical complications I'm
not sure about them like they could be
good for me but they can also be also be
bad because my Center is not well
supported I mean he never saw this at
night eggs and so on but it just it
works it sometimes happens that
something gets overlooked but still it
does work yeah I'm going to take him no
okay the M takes and now it takes with
the denied and somehow it works out for
black so between it yeah
for the shame read a real shame so I
should have played something something
normal right now now he's active 94 and
all kinds of stuff no anyway so I
probably should have just played a
normal move the thing is a position like
this is just crab of a player for I mean
black is just eternally worse so I
shouldn't have gone for any tactics
problem now is super active all of the
sudden I have three and so on the
position was excellent the register
don't do any tactics IAM just play
playing all that stuff yeah that's you
for my position now it's just bad
everything now makes sense for him
yeah I shouldn't have gone for the
tactics that was a bad idea i try to
refute this immediate leave it doesn't
work Chuck okay I didn't expect this
move at all hmm okay is that is this all
that bad
hmm i don't think so i don't think so
that this is so bad the Knights look a
little bit strange now that he has ok ok
taking d5 this is a good idea probably
how to play here hmm the knight on d5
doesn't really have all that great
squares night before also looks wrong
but I need to move it somewhere I mean I
cannot just stay only five on that super
unstable square maybe before d3 you want
or something like that it's just not
stable on d5 yeah I know this doesn't
look particularly active but I didn't
see something else or anything else I
think it's correct yeah you can sorry he
can win the exchange now but I wouldn't
be 6 let's see to Evan b6 it's that's
not that's not such a big deal i hope
remaining pieces look good is good
before though this could be an issue
really time morning before is a good
move just firing probably know this one
95 is not very good probably and this is
all so much great f 2x okay my
coordination is not that great if I can
somehow get these pieces a little bit
more coordinated what it wouldn't be all
that bad there should be seven probably
or maybe he wants to go look be one okay
check check
925 is a it's not a real threat even
it's not a completely trivial win but ok
at the time time situation is not
helping ok ok um yes why sigh yes this
is some this was just a totally stupid
thing I don't want to analyze much in
those shows but I mean ok 95 actually
does work but I do i can just do this
and I'm just better long-term a black
has no space white is just very
comfortably better I should do this and
not do something stupid technically
anyway so let's get to a new game
especially considering that I know how
we place is a purely technical player so
not a good idea ok got a new game
requests out
game started okay go to my way here with
black so I know it has a special line in
the in the cesarean so let's see let's
see my way no I have to play a 6 first
I've made this mistake more than once
now it's God might be five ah yes of
course I hate this I've made this
mistake before ah this is so unnecessary
I mean this line is just bad and if you
play a 6 not age 6 ok so let's see if I
can so get a game all of this this one
anyway
any other gadget Cassandra Williams has
b2600 GM with the slide in the same
that's possible he's beaten Grand
Masters with all kind of crap just
because he's an extremely talented
attacker the lines are often totally
unsound but they are dangerous and
impractical games you can have all kinds
of success with stuff like that yeah I
like this snow I play h6 which is mostly
a finger fila but this is just if just
totally bad now
so what can I somehow still play this
position
yeah this is complete complete garbage
here this position probably but many
things win here probably and this is one
of them okay hooray i can develop a
piece i made the same mistake before
it's the crazy thing that's the same
mistake why is he going down
you
okay Bishop c4 or what Knight a5 maybe
night a 538 for yes he has all kinds of
discoveries coming up Knight a5 Queen a
494 I'm getting killed with this no that
doesn't work isn't there some way to
somehow play this stuff still if I take
theirs Bishop f4 coming
yeah it's just a pretty okay Bishop f4
honey that can take be five actually
well then yes Queen you too but anyway
hey this is such a rubbish position so
at least I get castle there this is
smaller than I expected I think at least
I get cancelled let's do it gasoline
great so yeah that's all I have a check
small victories
I have to fight now here with this
position of pulling down
yeah I mean I don't think I should have
gotten out of this alive but somehow it
happened
where do i go on the fifth-ranked there
is looking five huh and here there's 95
and you can take on f6 oh my god time
morning great stuff anyway
yeah this is absolutely absolutely
terrible um yeah it it's a case of it
doesn't really matter if i get an ending
here that would be fantastic oh my god i
get an ending i mean it's it's not a
great ending but maybe this first and
then take I'm not sure that I I mean f2
is hanging right and no I'm saying yes
yes I'm running into a checkmate just
just a moment where again in the game
okay come on I put the main on the board
yes thank you and I should really learn
that I have to play a 6 first and black
is fine and not h 6 i'm just an idiot
yeah this is just not a good position
for why there because the bishop on g5
is completely wrong but yeah anyway okay
so a new game please identify I've done
the same thing beforehand 7 got killed
anyway let's see get getting a new game
I have to add just have to prevent 95 I
mean this is not winning for black or
anything but it is a it is come home
side promate a or 77 who is that
yeah same start as in the game against
your cheek we played c65 most people
play d 6 in this position okay he's ya
next time i will remember maybe yeah but
sometimes I feel like I just have I
don't know it's extremely idiotic em to
stumble into this okay tomatillo this is
a fairly standard English opening
position it can transpose um position
type wise to fe and Kato Kings then you
will see what he does lucky for him
there's nothing wrong with g4s just I'm
playing on seafoam were at the moment
experimenting with this and using the
knowledge that I had gathered to are
compiling this repertoire t5 is a
strange move Oh is he going 94 now he
probably has to hear otherwise that
doesn't make any sense 97 f 4 is
terrible ma'am he had to go head to go
forward that actually is interesting as
f4 is not easily played here hmm
interesting
here's a technically five here very
interesting if I take you for hmm very
tricky position ok I'm going to take I
think and now is the question what to do
now maybe a Tekkit like that
it seemed
hmm interesting he's attacking III here
and I would like not to get my pawn
structure completely crushed
you
hmm quite sure you're not be five is not
working it's close but it doesn't work I
know actually it is possible i can take
the aid okay
ok but this now should be just bad of a
white I mean like a lot 93 is not
working it's close but okay if I take
you five and drew a five at the end I
can still take can still take this take
their through p8 look T 1 is an
alternative as your t8 doesn't make any
sense so I can go with D 1 and I
shouldn't have blundered that ah it's
not good to give this a way to be honest
it's really not because it's kind of
useful to it would have been kind of
useful to have b3 to give better
protection to the bishop it is still
fairly good but not comparable to what I
would have when I could have gotten
yeah that was terrible I had a
completely winning position and
blundered to be porn and this is really
it was an important one that was a
really important part check check so
when I am Knight to c4 would be good but
that's a long way check
why morning check still have some time
left it's not completely hopeless that I
wouldn't ever make it check what okay he
might just draw with the with the ponies
ha ha ha and yeah of course haha yeah I
don't know I thought I don't know okay
so let's see for a new game yeah I mean
this was really terrible I just just
just have to keep me too I didn't really
pay attention that that was hanging I
can play be three or something if I keep
the corner I think this is a fairly easy
win okay anyway let's get a new game
going it was super complicated yeah but
once he blundered I should have won this
but what can you do you cannot be no
more definitely not so got a new request
out whoa many good players online we
don't have only gas on he featured two
times last week
gain Charlotte requested what a journey
no I don't do it Jone if you like you
can avoid it the journey scrub gain
abort it sometimes sometimes you you
click click the click the wrong thing or
something that I usually agree to
rewards if they if they happen and no
i'm not playing the halloween gambit i'm
sorry i had a request for that for the
dutch which I which I played basically
with c4 f5 okay so got a new request out
who we have we have sauerkraut on would
be a cool opponent
Lawrence trend is on but his rating is
really low so it seems it's very
unlikely that i get paired with them
it's a little bit slow is share five
minute at the moment what's going on a
couple of good games going on but i
don't get paired somehow game started w
jim who by yeah she's a good player i've
played it before there were one or two
games where I had bad positions and
somehow i swindled wat whatever regaled
my way out of it so let's see i'm
playing this Ruby one line in that in
the English and she allows before I am
let's do it
there's a there's some tequila was as a
best game in the centuries not from my
ipad middle man vs Fang millman roses
fanger that doesn't really ring a bell
so I would be first of all what is going
on here why isn't that the pawn on e5
for me let's see
if I take that what is the deal here
Bishop five maybe or something I don't
quite like Bishop 5d3 you should have
six something like that I can go F for I
don't quite see it so I'm taking
middlemen roses Fang that doesn't ring a
bell at all what I have to say though I
mean that vie he game I think it's
arrogance bruise on right where he
sacrificed um I was like what was I was
an excellent game of course but I really
absolutely not think it's something
extraordinary why people think that
would be the best game ever seems very
weird to me and in fact I think most
people they are talked about it agreed
jab stronger players it said like okay
what's the deal everything this is
nothing special I'm sorry it just it is
nice but it's nothing out of the
ordinary so what's going on here Bishop
c3 Bishop takes you two three maybe I
mean don't get me wrong I would be I
mean exceptionally proud to have played
this ye game it's just that um I feel
for strong GM this is like nothing
special ready if they get the
opportunity they will play like that
okay so I'm to Pont no one pawn up look
before here i guess i need to move the
rook here rupee form would be to looks
weird group if maybe just to a one now I
wouldn't wear wear a clown costume I
really I really don't like costumes that
much so it doesn't doesn't really isn't
really on
I would wear a santa hat yeah I would do
that but not a clown costume I never
liked clowns okay Quinn age for this is
getting somewhat serious here she
definitely has some compensation him
maybe I should have fled route before I
should have done that this is sucks he
is really sucks the main i mean III
looks ugly I just want to get to f3 with
the Queen and then possibly to g3 just
straight to a trade when Black is fine
very fine i will she retreats really
that i did not expect so okay let's
let's do this
and amid the bishop hmm I really thought
she would take playbook the age that
looked very very good for black and yet
I don't know maybe I'm just overlooking
things possible but yeah I feel I'm fine
yeah Leahy I'm fine I have to watch out
for the time though I'm really down on
the clock Queen g3 I absolutely want to
trade Queens I mean okay my king
position is not that bad but yeah my my
Center head yeah i know my pronunciation
is sometimes weird so center as in Santa
Claus maybe she can take play nazi for
right yeah 95 probably doesn't do all
that much there's no this Bishop g5
and rookie one they can't hear she can
take okay wow I didn't see that move
coming very aggressive time morning I
don't like this position still she's got
extremely good player from the exchange
very good play
check
a bad position maybe she overlooks root
g 6 which is a very cheap drag
admittedly but it's a pretty bad
position anyway Brooke trade i think i'm
basically happy about I should go to see
40 blunder don't blunder this since this
is friggin porn huh ok what a bad
position and they also have no time
absolutely no time
is there anything that I can do though
the rook doesn't have many squares but
it's probably not a big deal check check
yeah what the heck check check check
check check check black forfeits on time
hmm that that wasn't a good game yeah
anyway what can you do I won that on
time I really wonder you how did I get
killed all that badly I mean here
everything seems cool I probably I
probably am yeah Queen g3 is probably
bad I mean it is a bad structure but I I
really I really didn't expect my center
to be totally killed like that this is a
really really powerful idea
and the engine gives this with a big
advantage sure that's not easy to do
okay anyway I'm going for a new game
hope to play better this time yeah there
was a dude even Adam I'm kind of sick
with like granting drawers nope nobody
does that and they play every position
on time no matter how worse and i really
feel being mr. nice gay all the time
this kind of it's kind of lame to be
honest so let's see if i can get a new
game
game started Johnny ballgame okay you
wanted me to play what let's go see five
maybe we get Sicilian no yeah III m came
this is not so interesting d 4 is the
more okay now he goes before and the
more challenging idea and here this is
interesting if he goes back now which is
the normal normal choice I have some
ideas here sometimes to do even play for
a play on the kingside 3 and 93 not
particularly expected so let's do it h
dr h for checkmate whoosh yo Nate c7 I
have to address
Bishop takes I have g5 funny funny trick
i think i have this p 2 is also hanging
by the way but i don't think i'm not
sure that this ever is an idea ok so
here there are various ideas I can take
to I can check on g4 if I go clean g4 is
got 93 so and as you can still take be
too probably he will just suck sacrifice
something then i think i will still take
this I mean I'm attacking two things and
I actually want to play f6 to get rid of
his Bishop yeah that's all cool i'll
take this and now i have sex because i
actually i want to take on h4 with the
rook in this way my bishop on g7 is not
dead and in the process I've I've backed
an exchange oh my god and what the heck
meow I see the point if I take twice he
takes h3 again it just move the king
okay that's a funny position I mean like
everything hangs okay I never really
threatened g5 as the Queen on a oneness
relevant but now I'm threatening to take
stuff on g 27 and I'm an exchange up
already so material wise everything's
cool okay so if i just take here so that
that's a piece right of a piece up now
okay the piece is a piece is a piece 25
hmm let's cover that
I don't think Knight takes f6 worked
white resigns hmm yeah you know this is
actually a very serious idea what entity
this is not just like some some blitz
blitz nonsense this is actually really
dangerous it's something that especially
after night 83 this is dangerous um
normally normally a wide place 93 and
even with this which is really more of a
defending piece and the night on a three
is this h5 business is dangerous so um
maybe one more game I'm kind of gets got
some winds in even though I lost this
this two-game said they were stupid
ready but ok let's mock one more game
one more game
game started do you low whisper Lulu
don't ever played her is that chili oh
yeah chili ok so the double fee i canno
this is not a bad line it's just that
people tend to play the quadruple
fianchetto against me whether if you
care of everything and this is often not
very interesting this is this is ok
we're probably transposing into a um an
English opening Oh 97 that's interesting
ok let's just support the center a
little bit what is flex idea 'if I've
hmm ok let's just develop if you take
Steve or I will always get it back with
95 and things like that a six covering
be five okay maybe just this one I mean
II for looks very loose I might still be
able to do it efore 92 f five looks a
tad too ambitious if you ask me but may
be possible let's see what he how he
does know it takes ok 94 looks normal I
just wonder if you had some tactics
don't think so so let's take
that looks fine maybe Knight to e5 or
something like that he needs to develop
his pieces somehow looks a bit
uncomfortable for black his structure is
very much very much damage with the pawn
on d6 and my my two bishops
my two bishops ideally placed yeah he
takes takes a while I don't know maybe
we piayed on something like this yeah
the thing is i don't know if i have a
much better move than something that
Queen d2 but i think i'm going to play
it just double up on the dearborn
difficult for him to get some activity
night it's not just six good here it's
just excellent actually I think yeah if
that's if you have to do that that's a
bad sign so all the way back and now
we'll win d 5 I don't think you can take
on c4 Quincy three looks absolutely
deadly okay wow whoa whoa whoa okay okay
okay f6 um let's see
green age 6 f 6
between 2025 six and taking all
don't see a totally clean win really
hear that seem check this is what I what
I felt is good at d 6 + f6 is hanging
there were of course alternatives it was
difficult to choose from many good good
things this is pretty good okay so what
do I can take here I know you want to
win by made but taking everything is
also quite good
yeah that wasn't all that clear right I
mean it wasn't hired what I did but it
wasn't necessary to do this temporary
sacrifice there but it's two pawns and
still really easy to win take or rugby
one rupee one yeah you wanna c 0 I need
the king
yet the bishop is also dominating the
night here quite badly check check the
King can now decide things on the under
on the King side I think we gave eight
maybe claw hmm ok I wanted to go Kings
you forward it doesn't look good let's
do it like that I don't want to give up
f2
can just basically we direct the rook
towards them the kingside points that
are weak I Group C 1 and then enter yeah
here I thought before behind us the
trick okay I can just push the poor now
check check check black resigns okay so
when it was a fairly decent session in
terms of points I'm not quite sure about
my player needed them some luck and a
dirty time when to get along but I hope
you enjoy the show anyway I'll be a one
next week of course and also make sure
to check out the show on saturday
Saturday evening there will be the
similar master the monthly show that I'm
doing it will be 8 p.m. central european
time makes it 22 right 2 p.m. eastern
standard time yeah ok make sure to join
me on saturday and may also next week on
monday bye bye guys